le président Jaïr bolsonaro aime la moto
et c'est en convoi de moto et à San
Paolo qui a choisi de terminer sa
campagne pour le premier tour la
propagande politique est terminée depuis
hier soir mais certaines activités sont
encore permises
et partisans c'est peu probable selon
les sondages mais ces partisans y
croient sa base électorale est de 30 à
36% mais elle est solide voire fanatique
cette base ne bougera pas mais le reste
de la population brésilienne va voter
demain sur la base du bilan de 4 ans de
Jaïr bolsonaro un bilan que plusieurs
analystes jugent désastreux à de
nombreux points de vue du point de vue
de l'environnement du point de vue de
l'éducation du point de vue de la
culture du peu de vue de la science
c'était vraiment un désastre de les
politiques publiques vers les plus
vulnérables ils sont rarement détruits
en face l'ex-président Lula Louis
ignaccio Da Silva le bilan de ces deux
mandats est mitigé les scandales de
corruption qui entaché les gouvernements
du Parti des travailleurs ont laissé des
traces alors si les Brésiliens le
choisissent c'est qu'ils le
considèreront comme un moindre mal
l'ex-président Lula s'est engagé à
reconstruire ces institutions et à
réinvestir dans les programmes sociaux
nécessaires pour sortir le tiers des
Brésiliens de la pauvreté dans laquelle
ils vivent c'est ce qu'il avait réussi
de mieux dans son premier mandat il
devra aussi apaiser la violence qui
sous-tend le discours de Jair bolsonaro
les milices
annoncent on lutte contre les
institutions et contre le stables mais
en même temps dit que la façon de faire
ça c'est armer les gens et créer des
réseaux qui sont j'y crois en limite
criminelle qui sont capables de
substituer l'état un lendemain
d'élection sans violence est-ce que tout
le monde aux espérer mais quand au
premier tour ou dans un deuxième tour le
30 octobre les deux derniers sondages
qui viennent tout juste de tomber
donnent encore une légère avance à Lula
avec 50 et 51%, mais ça lui garantit pas
forcément une victoire dès le premier
tour Jean-Michel Leprince Radio-Canada
Rio de